[Music]
80-year I'm a program manager on the
cool for education team you may have
seen me on the edu and ninety series so
glad you could join us 80 so in today's
episode we're going to talk about a
critical part of any business protection
and management of data and mismanagement
of sensitive information can come at
real costs the challenge is how to
protect sensitive data while still being
able to use it for important business
functions like running analytics or
customer support operations well we've
got an answer for this cloud data loss
prevention API we'll also run through a
quick demo of the self-paced lab bra
we'll set up a DLP API and use it to
inspect a string of data for sensitive
information so when it comes to properly
handling sensitive data the first step
is knowing where it exists well the DLP
API uses a variety of techniques
identify since the data like credit card
numbers Social Security numbers names
and other forms of personally
identifiable information in addition to
identifying sensitive data within text
content the API can detect and classify
sensitive data within standard bitmap
images to applying the API to text reams
allows you to automatically redact or
censor any sensitive data before it
writes to disk generates logs or is used
to perform analysis tests identifying
sensitive data upfront also allows you
to choose the most suitable storage
system and appropriate access controls
for that data the DLP API classifies raw
data by using a set of predefined
detectors to identify patterns formats
and checksums
the API can even understand contextual
clues once you know what your sensitive
data lives the API gives you the option
to de-identify that data so what does
that mean d identifying data removes
identifying information from a data set
making it more difficult to associate
the remaining data with an individual
and reducing the risk of exposure the
resulting data is then suitable for apps
storage or analysis redaction removes
entire values or entire records from a
data set partial masking hides parts of
the data leaving some data visible for
example the last seven digits of a u.s.
telephone number tokenization or secure
hashing replaces sensitive data with a
key
this is often used in credit card
processing dynamic data masking applies
de-identification and masking techniques
in real-time this can be useful if you
don't want to alter your underlying data
but want to mask it wouldn't viewed by
certain users especially access
privileges could be applied for those
who need to view it say HR or finance
team the DLP API integrates with many of
our other GCP services to cloud
functions can help you automate the
classification of data that's uploaded
to cloud storage also there's a built-in
support for scanning and classifying
sensitive data in cloud storage cloud
datastore and bigquery cloud pub/sub
notifications can be generated in
response to completed inspection jobs we
then created a service account to access
the Google cloud api's when testing
locally and gave the service account the
required permissions we then generated a
service account key so first we create a
JSON file with sensitive information in
this case it's a phone number
we authenticate to our service account
passing the location of the service
account key file and obtain an
authorization token using the service
account we can then use the curl command
to inspect the JSON file for sensitive
information and the response shows that
the phone number was found with a
likelihood of likely we can also redact
sensitive information we create a second
JSON file this time with a sensitive
email address we can then use the curl
command to de-identify the JSON file for
sensitive information we can see the
response that the email address has been
replaced well that's the end of another
episode we hope you enjoyed it if you've
got some great examples of how you've
been able to apply this API please share
it with us
and make sure to check out the link
where you can apply what you learned
today and use a three hundred dollar
free trial credit at Google cloud
platform here all of our additional
training resources are linked below
thanks for watching see you soon
[Music]
you
[Music]